one of the things that I noticed was
there's this this difference between
your fans who you love like when they're
telling you they love you and these
especially these young women who you've
who you mean so much to and they're
going crazy and they love it and then at
a certain point when it's if it's
hundreds of thousands of people
I would think it starts to get I it's
overwhelming is that does that it's
straight it's a it's weirdly in a way
um underwhelming when there's more
people right so like you know I played I
played my first stadiums over the summer
and I was playing markets that I hadn't
played before so I hadn't been there so
I could a lot of people wanted to go and
I didn't want to do you know five shows
in an arena so might as well do a
stadium or two stadiums or whatever so I
did a couple stadiums over the summer
and like that was really exciting
because I was like ooh are we in a
stadium it's so sick it's so big you're
a star and then you're on the
stage and it's like you feel like you're
just alone and then there's like a it
feels like there's a printed out
wallpaper of thousands of people because
they're so far away that there's like no
intimacy I mean I talked to I I went to
the Super Bowl the other day and I was
sitting in a box with Adele I
thought people do we were talking about
it because I didn't see you there that's
weird
you know the name drop thing where
people say the first name of the person
and then they say the last name like you
go like I was on Conan O'Brien like this
yeah you can't do that with Adele no you
can't that's with Adele Adele is just
Adele but anyway we were talking about
it because she's doing this this Vegas
residency and she's just you know not to
out her but she said she's having a
the time of her life and she's
like I love that it's it's like a 4 000
cap room and she's like it's so nice I
feel like I can be there with them
I don't know
I can't write a song about that
um
I this is what I this is what I have
found is that uh uh when I in comedy
there's this it's the same thing as in
uh music that
it's supposed to be the best when you
get to a stadium
uh or and I've never obviously never
played a stadium but I've played some
really big spaces and I've thought
I don't like this as much and then you
think what's the magic number I think
it's like 1500 2000 somewhere around
there is The Sweet Spot of I feel like
everybody in this room
we're all connecting it's an exchange
yeah like if I say something that they
think is funny they laugh and you can
kind of there's this nice feeling of uh
it's a community community yeah once it
gets really big and there's a lot of
things about success that are like that
where you're facing new challenges of
like now you've got people that will
people that will say like okay I want to
be I want to do what you two did I want
to be like that and then you're trying
to think of you know but I want to
evolve I don't want to I want to keep
changing I want to keep growing and uh
so you've got new battles that you
didn't have
two years ago
I've been I've been in a in a I've been
drowning in a pool of that recently just
like what am I where do I how do I
evolve and what do I do and you know
I've just I feel like for the last month
I've been I've been completely
just literally like drowning I feel like
I because dude I mean I I I achieved the
kind of things before I even was 18 that
are you know things that you people work
their entire lives for and maybe never
even get and maybe and like one of the
things that I achieved is like one thing
someone gets at the end of their life
and one other you know when I got all of
them you know and and I'm 21 now and I'm
I'm in a point where I'm like
I've done it all I'm like what do I what
am I gonna do now and like where do I go
from here and who do I want to be
because I've also only ever been a
teenage Billy eilish and so that's the
person I thought I was and then I got to
a certain age and I was like oh that was
Teenage me that's right I thought I
thought I was being my I was like oh I'm
myself and this is who I am and you know
it was the way it was but it was a me as
a teenager and it's very strange to to
grow up and become an adult and like
the person that you you kind of finally
figured out how to be in like the like
the perfect way that everybody thinks is
who you are is yourself as a teenager
it's very jarring and uh hard to
deal with well I was I was really happy
that your parents came there they are
outside yeah they're outside I wouldn't
let them in
um your father got in here twice and I
and I'm taken out and I I had someone
shave his beard
um why yeah yeah I like it it looked
really cool but I just I have that kind
of power you're in my building okay
right so um no he's uh
I think one of the things
that you two have that is rare
um especially because you're both so
young when this all started when this
was happening is to have your parents
there and have them be really decent
people who have their heads screwed on
right it just doesn't happen I think
nine out of ten times it doesn't happen
and uh
that's that's a godsend that's really
special I mean I'm sure there are
moments where like why are they on the
tour bus
[Laughter]
very rarely it's really fun I love
having my parents out yeah yeah there
there was a moment over the summer where
I was having like a
I need to be an adult moment and like I
need to have space and I need to have I
need to have my ownness and my own net
and I need to go on tour alone and I
need to do this and this and this alone
I want to be independent and
I do need that in in a lot of ways
because you know you need that as you
grow older but then
also now I'm like well I like I like my
parents being around and I like my mom
coming and doing stuff with me okay
Billy doesn't Billy moved away I did
move away and I think when you don't
live with your folks anymore you're dude
yeah it's nicer to it makes you more
grateful yeah do everything with them so
I'm like now I just like I I you know
when I have a free a free night I like
go and hang out with my parents that's
the first thing I think of doing what is
the pattern I mean I've seen it with uh
with my daughter which is she was you
know very smart independent cool
artistic and then I I could tell we were
getting on our nerves and then she went
off to college and she'd come back from
college and she would ask us to do
things that we know for a fact she can
do on her own she'll be like
for me a glass of milk like you mean the
carton of milk that's right there in the
pretty please and you could tell like
she just wanted to be back into the
street this girl's drinking just regular
milk I don't know she has no she has a
flask of scotch that she has on her that
she pours into the milk okay that's how
we do it makes it even weirder yeah this
is a whole we're talking whole milk two
person this is not even like an L.A I
thought you didn't aren't you aren't you
isn't she a nepo baby aren't you isn't
she on oat milk or almond milk or
pistachio milk
you've got this girl on two percent yeah
yeah two percent no I live in the
Palisades and uh I'm a celebrity so I
found a special nine percent milk
got huge chunks
the one percent milk yeah
there you go got it no I drink the one
percent of the one percent milk Only
Adele gets that